well Kevin this sure wasn't the
time-warp but it was fun to watch this
yes that is Rob Lowe jumping around
shirtless on The Late Show with Stephen
Colbert tonight Rob gets down to serious
business on the season premiere of code
black and I was there when dr. lo had to
save this first life
this is officially day number one this
is my first day first scene first rescue
does it feel like the first day of
school
I can't even compare it to anything
because my first take I'm jumping out of
a helicopter
there's jet engines blowing fans there
are two bodies on the beach there no 30
extras there's blood paraphernalia it's
overwhelming it's Rob Lowe to the rescue
all right he's losing too much weight
he's not gonna make it back unless we
stabilize him right here Rob makes his
debut on the medical drama as military
dr. Ethan Willis and we caught his very
first mission saving a shark attack
victim somebody get her away please step
back
Rob that a crew-cut for the role and
some pretty intensive training so did
you go through a boot camp of your own
and kind of what what kind of day was
like class he was classically at uh four
or five different trauma cases set up
and you would we would all rotate
through him so there was sutures would
be one another we how to intubate
someone the other would be how to put in
a chest line
a pig it works
should work if I'm walking down the
beach I don't see the pitchfork in the
sand and I impale myself you could save
me right now I I could save you cuz I
have learning some stuff I'm code black
I got your back if you need a Heimlich
you